el comandante del vehículo está al mando del operador
el artillero trabaja con el cañón, y yo
Por supuesto que es difícil estar al mando.
Es difícil pensar en un almacén especial cuando todos
en posiciones
cada llegada Esto es difícil, piensas
Lo principal es no golpear a nadie.
Esto es lo más difícil
[música]
por mi parte yo también lo intento
ayudar tanto como sea posible
y psicológicamente así
Realizamos allí cualquier trabajo que sea necesario
sean mujeres o no
[música]
moral en nuestro servicio en
nivel alto
todos quieren visitar sus clubes
casi tus propios seres queridos
cubierto de todo lo que se lo doy
Crecí demasiado en el proceso en mi pensamiento, así que
zhenya
abrirse y desmoronarse por ti, nuestro teteem
No puedes
Después de todo, las historias las cuentan las personas.
Pero eres más hermosa que tus parientes.
decir que los extraños no son tuyos
decir
[música]